what's going on guys this is rob and
it's Christmas time yes it is I got
myself a Brita water bottle and I feel
like it's been a while since we've done
like a video like this I kind of Miss
doing these videos right it's kind of
like talk to you guys for a little while
um I mean this was not gonna be a super
long video but you know I do kind of
Miss you know doing that occasionally
but yeah you know as you guys know
around this time of year normally I
would do some kind of a christmas thing
but let you know last year I did a video
about when Santa Claus got the Infinity
Gauntlet and it was a little too page
story but people sort of give me hate
because it wasn't like a 20 minute long
video can't really make a 20 minute
video out of a two minute story and you
know people were like well if you can't
make a 20 minute video editor to it to
issue store a two page story then
there's no point in trying to make a you
shouldn't make a video about it and so I
was like okay so at that point I
canceled doing any kind of like
Christmas or holiday themed videos so
what we're gonna do is I'm actually
gonna take a break for this week spend
time with your families everybody I mean
you know hang out with friends and if
you're crazy enough like brave the mall
and go shopping I'm not going to I I'm
no way like well I probably will to be
honest but nonetheless you know it's the
holiday season you know time to spend
time with our families it's time to you
know take a break from work and
different things like that you know and
for me YouTube's no exception so I'm
gonna take a break from things I'm
probably play some video games hang out
with some friends hanging out with some
family my friends a friend actually
Brian is making some home brew some
cider that he's that he's bringing into
town so I'm really excited about that
because he makes pretty good pretty good
alcohol pretty good beer stuff like that
but um anyway yeah so I'm I go ahead and
and bounce off here but I want to blend
that by you guys and let you guys know
that you know if you're not seeing any
videos like hummus explained then the
reason why is because of the fact that
I'm just kind of taking a break i'll
probably still upload a couple videos
here and there for Rob explain simple
because those videos are so quick to
make but also because i'm still trying
to grow that channel and so I need to
make sure that videos are constantly
being uploaded to ensure that channel
grows like it's supposed to but um yeah
so I guess that's pretty much it next
week we start back with everything that
here to discussions that kind of good
stuff I'll have a video I'm sorry a
upload schedule down in the description
of this video you can check out so it'll
give you an idea of when i'll be
uploading content but yeah so uh I guess
it's pretty much it oh yeah episode 7
was amazing if you guys haven't seen any
I'm not gonna spoil anything but if you
haven't seen it yet like it's really
good like you should really go see it
it's pretty awesome but anyway um I will
catch you guys later peace